over the last year and a half to two
years we've seen a real resurgence of
pseudo-intellectual thinking especially
led by this internet movement that I
think people who watch this show are
sort of familiar with and there was an
article in The New York Times recently
by Barry Weiss that has gotten a lot of
attention writing about what some are
calling the intellectual dark web and I
didn't agree with nearly everything that
she wrote in the piece but she does do
an interesting job of exposing people to
the fact that this movement exists
I guess maybe movement is the word I
don't even know if we can really call it
a movement and explaining to people sort
of some of the players involved in some
of the ideology involved and I don't
even really know exactly who's part of
this movement the article in The Times
talked about sam harris jordan peterson
eric weinstein dave rubin ben shapiro a
lot of different people were mentioned
and most of the people described in the
article are certainly not intellectuals
by any stretch of the imagination but I
think that the more interesting part is
less about the intellectuals or
pseudo-intellectuals themselves and more
about why they are increasingly why
there is a group that is increasingly
attracted to those types of characters
and as I've said before and we've talked
about pseudo intellectual ism a lot on
the program to really fight back against
pseudo intellectual ism you have to
understand the two sides of the problem
and in the New York Times article and
elsewhere some of the people I mentioned
will ascribe to their followers a desire
for truth and truly open debate about
all ideas with no taboo topics as the
reason for their success right their
story is people are so starved for real
discussion about real issues because of
the repression of the liberal media and
political correctness and sometimes they
blame post-modernism that there was just
this overwhelming pent-up demand for
exactly what these intellectual dark
Weber's or whatever you want to call
them or offer
now I completely disagree and it's a
two-part issue as to how it all happened
the first part is why do we have a
population that's particularly receptive
right now to pseudo-intellectual ideas
that can sometimes sound unique and
correct and accurate and then part two
is the sort of inability to distinguish
between real intellectual thought real
critical thinking real seeing of
knowledge or seeking knowledge for the
sake of knowledge versus just pseudo
intellectual nonsense that sounds pretty
good without really saying anything
unique or even in many cases substantive
so let's start with part one the
environment I've spoken about that quite
a bit there are people right now who
feel disassociate they feel as though
whatever real or perceived status they
have may be on the brink of going away
and they have been primed to accept faux
intellectual nonsense that seems to
explain why it is that they're
experiencing what they're experiencing
and maybe even present some ideas as to
how they might be able to stop it or fix
the problem they see they've been
conditioned that academia is just
liberal indoctrination and bad or that
actual intellectualism is bad that they
won't get the real truth because of
censorship and political correctness and
all of that stuff and that view exists
more on the right but not exclusively
there are left-wing elements to this as
well for sure there are people on the
Left who have also fallen for movements
like men's rights activism that they
won't get the truth about the oppression
of men because evil feminists won't
allow the truth to come out or sjw's or
whoever then there's the question of
aside from being primed for
pseudo-intellectual answers to why the
world is the way it is why do they fall
for the faux intellectual nonsense
specifically from some of the people
were now seeing and a lot of it is
presentation style right it's how people
speak it's marketing period they they
hear the seemingly esoteric language but
they understand it because the truth is
what these people are selling and it's
not actually difficult to understand for
them the truth is it's not unique or
notable
either but it's very appealing the
desire for the feeling of authority that
knowing the real truth brings to them is
this is a big tractor beam to borrow a
phrase from Star Wars and they heard
from someone who's managed to get around
censorship that these are the people
that are gonna tell you the real truth
with no political correctness getting in
the way and a lack of context is often
what makes the phone intellectual
nonsense effective right people hear
ideas that sound good enough and they're
different than what they've been told
before so they buy it without
considering the real implications of
those ideas in the real world and in the
end there's a lot about simply people
that command authority as a factor here
right sometimes it's people that speak
quickly like ben shapiro or loudly or
eloquently like jordan Peterson or
whatever right there's a that's a huge
factor the optics of the presentation
and that's actually a really similar
mechanism as to what's at play within
the world of pseudoscience which we'll
be dealing with in a minute mini-series
soon but there's also some overlap with
the conspiracy theories I've explained
before that with conspiracy conspiracy
theories the appeal is sometimes simple
and neat explanations which even if
untrue are more comforting than the
truth which is often some version of the
world is a gray area of unpredictability
period right so look I'll give you an
example to illustrate the point from the
conspiracy world rather than we were
attacked by people on 9/11 and we either
couldn't or didn't stop it and people
randomly died it was a it was a tragedy
with a huge random element to it it's
more comforting to some to believe that
9/11 was controlled and planned maybe
even by people in our government maybe
george w bush combined with a world
trade center that was painted with
thermite the walls were painted with
thermite paint for years to make the
building catch on fire more easily and
the analogy with pseudo-intellectual ISM
is for example take the race and IQ
discussion which has become very popular
rather than recognizing and evaluating
the multi-generational socio
economic issues that on a test like IQ
lead to what appear to be correlations
of race and IQ so on and so forth
instead how about some races are just
smarter period inherently right or
another example from the so-called
intellectual dark web there are real
differences between men and women that's
a popular one yeah does does anybody
deny that that's not original that's
what really gets to me about the so
called intellectual dark web I've heard
nothing unique from any of them and I
mean you know looking at their full
range of topics
Jordan Peterson's book twelve rules for
life assume that the person you are
listening to might know something you
don't
Wow wait a second you go back and you
read how to win friends and influence
people by Dale Carnegie from 1936 and
his book is filled with the exact same
idea be a good listener encourage others
to talk about themselves let the other
person do a great deal of the talking
try to honestly see things from the
other person's point of view there's
nothing even remotely notable about
jordan Peterson's twelve rules of life
or for life or whatever another example
is the idea around free speech and
censorship that right there are a lot of
people activated by this intellectual
dark web movement because they feel like
they can't say what they want to anymore
there's nothing remarkable about that I
grew up around people like that the sort
of hill town folks from around the
Northampton Massachusetts area they
believe that the political correctness
of the college towns in in the Pioneer
Valley were suffocating them and
preventing them from saying what they
wanted to say although it was never
really clear what it was they wanted to
say that they actually couldn't say
that's not unique it's not new it's not
even notable in any way or free speech
as a meta issue that trumps all other
issues that's another calling card of
the intellectual dark web anyone who has
thought about meta issues in political
and economic society almost always
includes the role of speech at the top
of the list I included along with how
politics are financed the media world
and our economic system those are the
meta issues there is nothing unique or
notable there
let's take a more specific example one
of the sort of common ideas that I'm
seeing on the intellectual dark web is
ideas around taxation right where what
we have is unfair it punishes success
and you end up with some version of a
flat tax or a semi flat tax that's
getting presented now is some kind of
compromise between who knows what
arbitrary positions on either side flat
taxes have been floating around forever
right it's it's not unique it's not new
it's not even remotely interesting and
that is why it is abundantly clear that
the entire intellectual dark web dark
web movement is not an intellectual
movement it's a movement around
marketing and presentation style
combined with using the Internet and
social media period that is all there's
nothing unique period and the solution
sadly is not real intellectuals right if
you think that real intellectuals will
solve the problem of pseudo intellectual
ism that's like thinking if I just
explained the facts about gay marriage
to my homophobic cousin he'll
immediately change his mind we actually
know that the opposite is often true
being presented with information that
seeks to disprove or contradict your
worldview our understanding of the world
will often just further ingrain you in
those beliefs the real problem is the
environment in which the faux
intellectual nonsense of these people is
not only able to take hold but actually
welcomed with open arms as I described
earlier in this discussion and that's
what I don't know how to change the faux
intellectuals the intellectual dark web
and all of that stuff is a consequence
of the problem that we have in society
which I've identified for a long time in
many conversations about both anti
intellectualism and pseudo intellectual
ism so send me your thoughts about how
I've laid this out if I'm wrong change
my mind
tell me what unique or notable ideas are
actually coming out of the so called
intellectual dark web I'm on twitter at
des Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
so let's reset a little bit as we
transition to
I already spoke earlier in the show
about how Donald Trump is now very
interested in helping China regain jobs
when I thought the goal was to get jobs
back from China for Trump and it seems
to coincide with the news of a 500
million dollar contribution alone
effectively from China to an Indonesian
Trump linked resort well the White House
was asked about it as they should have
been Sarah Huckabee Sanders apparently
off yesterday Deputy Secretary a deputy
press secretary Raj Shah ran yesterday's
press conference and he was asked a very
simple question which is a question that
has been has been suggested many times
in the last 24 hours which is how does
this not violate the emoluments Clause
of the Constitution it is the
president's business getting something
of value from a foreign government Raj
Shah wouldn't answer it and it's hard to
imagine how he even could answer it
let's check out the video the Trump
Organization is involved in a project in
Indonesia building hotels Golf Course
residences it's getting up to 500
million dollars in backing from the
Chinese government can you tell or you
know explain the administration's
perspective on a how this wouldn't
violate the emoluments Clause and be how
it wouldn't violate the president's own
promise that his private organization
would not be getting involved in new
foreign deals while he was present to
refer you to the Trump Organization but
I mean the Trump Organization can't
speak on behalf of the President as the
president the head of the federal
government the one who is who's
responsible who needs to assure the
American PM you're asking about a
private organisations dealings that may
have to do with a foreign government
that's not something that I can speak to
so the entire premise of the answer is
nonsense right Raj Shah says we can't
speak on on the behalf of the Trump
Organization we're not talking about the
Trump Organization we're talking about
number one the promise that candidate
Trump made that as president Trump he
would not be involved in any foreign
deals that relates to the president
we're also talking about the president
receiving something of value from a
foreign country seemingly a violation of
the emoluments clause if you went to the
Trump Organization and asked them they'd
correctly say we're just a private
company the emoluments Clause of
applies to government officials talk to
someone who represents Trump as a
government official and the one thing
that Raj's answer does sort of
illuminate is that there's a question at
this point as to whether there really is
separation between President Trump and
Trump the CEO of the Trump Organization
right the guy hasn't divested from his
businesses he continues to be aware of
their business activity and deals he
continues to benefit from them so really
it's almost like there is no difference
and Raja is either actually ignorant or
just playing stupid about the fact that
Trump as president is very involved with
the business of the Trump Organization
so even taken at face value the
statement by Raja makes no sense if
Shahs answer is this has to do with the
Trump Organization and not President
Trump the immediate next question should
be well does presidents Trump does
president Trump still have a financial
interest in the Trump Organization or
did he divest and obviously Shahs answer
would be you'd have to talk to his
personal attorney who at this point by
the way is in no position to really be
answering any questions dealing with a
potential indictment himself and Michael
Cohen this is the same strategy that was
employed by Sarah Huckabee Sanders
earlier this month remember this I just
wanted to ask you about something that
took place last week involving the
president's personal attorney Michael
Cohen he in court documents asserted
that he would assert his Fifth Amendment
rights and the story guy Hills lawsuit
which was filed against both him and the
president and you may recall that in
September of 2017 the president at a
campaign rally said the mob takes the
fifth and he also said if you're
innocent why are you taking the Fifth
Amendment do those ideas also apply to
Michael Colin as the president stand by
those comments I can't speak on behalf
of Michael Cohen I'd were free
it is disgusting that they get away with
us and during the same briefing Raj Shah
was asked why the hell is Trump tweeting
support for specific Chinese companies
and what led up to that also no answer
from Raj about that yes
so I've two questions for you first on
ZTE did the Chinese government give any
specific concession for the President of
the United States between in support of
a Chinese company the president has
asked secretary Ross to look into the
matter a consistent and on being why did
he issue has been raised at many levels
by the Chinese government with the with
various levels of our administration
raising the issue is enough to spawn a
presidential it's a significant issue of
concern of the Chinese government you
know and in our bilateral relationship
there's a give-and-take and we and we
discuss these issues this is what needs
to be immediately shut down and
investigated if Democrats do well in the
November midterms and you know Pat we've
been talking about the multiple prongs
of molars investigation right we've got
Trump Russia
we've got obstruction and possible
crimes witness tampering indy covering
up of attempts to stop Trump Russia and
then financial crimes of a sort of
pretty specific nature molars not
looking into the emoluments clause thing
to the best of my knowledge we need to
vote in November because the concerns
around constitutional violations are
massive growing and presumably outside
of molar scope yeah and even if
something's outside of Muller's purview
you can always delegate that
responsibility off of someone else like
send it to an attorney general in
another state so we've we have seen that
and I think we'll continue to see that
yeah of course the complexity
specifically when it's emoluments is
you're talking about the Federal
Constitution so then it becomes dubious
to send it to a State Attorney General
that is something that at the federal
level must be looked into it's
disgusting it is swamp filling and we
may have a president here who has indeed
violated the Constitution discuss this
with us on reddit david pakman.com slash
re d di t quick break back after this
okay I've told you before about the
evangelical support for Israel being
very heavily
driven by the belief that by supporting
Israel the second coming of Jesus Christ
will happen and depending on your flavor
of Christianity this will bring about
the rapture or the apocalypse or the end
times or the end of the world
whichever lovely phrase your sect
attributes to that event I've also told
you before about outrageous Fox News
host Jeanine Pirro who was at some point
a judge somewhere really scary to think
about and she combined her insanity with
the evangelical insanity around Israel
in one lovely segment where she praised
Donald Trump's decision to move the
embassy that the United States has in
Israel from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem as the
fulfillment of a Biblical prophecy
listen to Jeanine Pirro here just
gushing about how great Donald Trump is
Donald Trump's and Iranians who are the
descendants of Persia a message to
reflect on their own history right and
that it was the king of Persia who a
thousand years before Mohammed was even
born
that said Jerusalem was the capital of
the Jewish people's country Russia
there will be no Ottoman empires or
chien nations that will destroy
Jerusalem any longer Donald Trump
recognized history he like King Cyrus
before him fulfilled the Biblical
prophecy
the gods worshipped by Jews Christians
and yes yes Muslims that Jerusalem is
the eternal capital of the Jewish state
and that the Jewish people finally
deserve a righteous free and sovereign
Israel I notice she has that same weird
pronunciation of Jerusalem that Trump
had in that video where it didn't it
wasn't clear whether he was trying to
eat his tongue or maybe had a denture
issue I wonder if maybe it's like having
veneers that are too big or something
like that
crucial it's a weird did you notice that
Pat it's a weird thing that's going on
maybe it's connected to being a Trump
supporter in some way it would be hard
to draw that line yeah hard to parse it
out how is this news like how does this
count as news analysis these are quite
literally the rantings of a disjointed
and ignorant
and I wonder like do they know that this
is the biblical prophecy that ends with
the destruction of life or the rapture I
know some of them know that and love it
like they think that's just that's the
greatest thing nothing better than the
rapture but I think that that's part of
the story that some of these people are
missing and and the other just laughable
thing that shows you how transparently
devoid of any meaning all of this
nonsense is is that in reality the
relocation of an embassy doesn't have
anything to do with Biblical prophecy
right like Jerusalem as the real and
enduring capital of Israel either is or
is not but a nearly obese 71 year old
president saying that we're moving a
building from one city to another that
doesn't materially change the biblical
meaning of what's going on and that's
what sort of truly beneath evangelical
support for Israel it's this nonsense
where more than 50% of American
evangelical Christians believe literally
that Israel is a requirement for the
rapture or Armageddon or the apocalypse
call it what you want the end of the
world they want that right and they see
Jerusalem is ground zero for that and it
is really important to understand this
when you hear about the political
support that Israel gets from the right
which is by the way the same place where
a lot of anti-semitism exists as well
which is an interesting thing they don't
like Israel for the Jews or for the
great weather and beaches or for the
food of Tel Aviv they believe that
Israel will lead to the fulfillment of
their religious prophecy and these are
the same types who believe that the
Bible predicted 9/11 this is a death
cult of the most extreme proportions and
of course like every Biblical prophecy
nothing will happen
right these people won't be around to
see it they'll just say well it's gonna
happen at some point after I'm no longer
alive and it is vilde that this counts
as a news report on Fox News truly yes
yeah
and does judge Jeanine really think that
Trump is sitting around at the White
House eating his junk food watching Fox
News and he thinks you know what I'm
going to adhere to thousands of years of
Persian history I'm gonna be just like
King Cyrus that's
the president that we know and love yes
certainly it's not what he's thinking
but regardless they still see him as a
guy who is somehow I guess fulfilling
the prophecy and it's it's deranged and
it's depraved and apparently on Fox News
it counts as reasonable news commentary
which is the scariest thing of all we've
all of a sudden learned a lot about that
infamous Trump Tower meeting involving a
Russian lawyer named the Natalia vessel
and that's kaya Donald Trump jr. was at
the meeting Paul Manafort was at the
meeting Jared Kushner was at the meeting
and many others and by every indication
this was an attempt at collusion between
Donald Trump's campaign and Russia there
was a quid pro quo discussed where there
would be potentially a reduction in
sanctions through the Magnitsky Act in
exchange for the damaging dirt on
Hillary Clinton that Natalia
vasilevskaya
said that she would be able to provide
and over time we've debunked a lot of
the lies about this there was the lie
that Donald Trump jr. wasn't really
going into the meeting expecting dirt
the lie that the Russian lawyer wasn't
connected to the Russian government in
any way but only now have we really
learned about the testimony related to
that meeting because the Senate
Judiciary Committee in issuing a report
that they believe yes that there were
attempts by Russia to interfere with the
election in 2016 to help Donald Trump
also released twenty five hundred pages
of testimony and exhibits yesterday and
it is now clear beyond any doubt that
Donald Trump jr.
wanted to collude with Russia and the
big takeaways are number one the people
at the meeting said that no dirt about
Hillary was actually provided at the
meeting we knew that already it was
promised to be delivered later very good
number two because of testimony from
Renaud akhmad he's the Russian American
lobbyists who was at the meeting he
claimed that Donald Trump jr. knew
exactly what the meeting was about and
actually said early on during the
meeting quote I believe you have some
information for us so the idea that
Donald Trump jr. didn't think there was
going to be dirt didn't expect there to
be dirt is absolutely bogus
we also read about testimony from Rob
Goldstone who was involved in setting up
this meeting and he testified that
Natalia vessel nets kya did indeed
lobbied on jr. about those Russian
sanctions known as the Magnitsky Act and
how those sanctions should be lifted
we were also previously told that Jared
Kushner was only at the meeting for a
little bit of it and then left Rob
Goldstone testified under oath that
Jared Kushner stayed for the entire
meeting yet another possible Jared
Kushner lie and then we also learned
more about remember that quote that has
been attributed to Donald Trump jr.
where he was told about the possibility
of this dirt from Natalia vessel nets
kya and he said if it's later in the
summer I love it we now have the full
context of that email from Donald Trump
jr. which said thanks Rob I appreciate
that I am on the road at the moment but
perhaps I just speak to Ameen first
seems we have some time and if it's what
you say I love it especially later in
the summer could we do a call first
thing next week when I am back that's
not exactly the email and the language
used by someone who's not really
interested in the dirt and doesn't
really think that there would be dirt
that's the email of someone who wants to
as quickly as possible after he returns
from a trip get on the phone and figure
out when they might be able to have the
meeting with Natalia vessel that's kaya
we heard from Heather there was a in the
testimony that we saw transcripts of
there was a moment where Heather Sawyer
who's a counsel for Dianne Feinstein
asked Donald Trump jr. what did you mean
that you loved it what did you love and
she went on and said did you mean that
you loved potentially incriminating
information on Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump jr. said yes he was asked
in testimony whether he told Trump's
senior about the meeting and he says
that he did not very difficult to
believe he also said that he didn't
think there was anything wrong with
meeting a Russian lawyer promising dirt
on Hillary Clinton ahead of the election
and he also said he couldn't remember
whether he discussed the entire thing
with his father and that starts to
become the trend I didn't do anything
wrong
I also don't remember and I have a
really hard time believing that Donald
Trump jr. just has no recollection about
whether he told Donald Trump's senior
that he met with the Russian lawyer
promising dirt on the opponent if he's
lying about not remembering he actually
still can be prosecuted there is this
idea that floats around that if you just
say you don't remember you can't be
prosecuted because you're not saying
something one way or the other you can
actually be prosecuted for these
so-called intentional memory problems
very unlikely like I don't think Donald
Trump jr. is actually gonna get in
trouble for that but the gaps in his
memory are very very bizarre yeah like I
don't know how you would prove that he
did in fact remember correct but I think
it's pretty clear that Don jr. told his
dad about it because I think so it was
such a small organization that campaign
and this meeting after all took place at
Trump Tower plus what was it like a few
days after the meeting was planned Trump
promised damaging information on Hillary
Clinton yeah a national audience minutes
after the meeting took place
Trump was tweeting about those missing
33,000 emails so the timing of it is
even more suspect and we actually have a
bit a bit of transcript to put up on the
screen just another element here Donald
Trump jr. was asked according to this
document 25 minutes after the first call
ended related to this meeting
you made an outgoing call to that same
number but in between the two calls
there's another entry a call at 427 that
lasted four minutes from a blocked
number between a means call to you at
404 and your return called to him at 431
with whom did you have a call Donald
Trump jr. saying I have no idea and of
course 9 minutes later Donald Trump
tweeting for the first time about
Hillary Clinton's missing 33,000 emails
so the timing stinks the lack of memory
from Don Jr absolutely stinks and these
transcripts raise even more questions
the intent to collude and again it's not
a legal term that is a colloquial term
which can include a couple of different
crimes potentially the intent to collude
is abundantly crystal clear and we only
have more questions and even fewer
answers as a result of these transcripts
which we will obviously continue to
follow and see how they play into Robert
Muller's investigation send me your
thoughts what do you make of the
transcript I'm on twitter at
Pakman show is on twitter at david
pakman show think you're gonna like this
story it's from our favorite fox news
show Fox and Friends I'm gonna set it up
for you 5 Isis leaders were recently
captured by the American military okay
Donald Trump our fearless orange leader
tweeted about it on Thursday of last
week Donald Trump tweeting 5 most wanted
leaders of Isis just captured now of
course if trump's talking about it
there's a good chance Fox & Friends is
going to talk about it and of course Fox
and Friends did talk about it the next
day they made a whole show out of
talking about how the New York Times
didn't report about the capture of these
fire the killing rather of these capture
not the killing the capture of these
five Isis leaders I guess they were
implying that because the New York Times
doesn't like Trump they're gonna cover
up any time that Trump does something
good even though it's not really clear
what Trump did capture the five Isis
leaders anyway here's one of their hosts
I can't even keep up with who's on that
show at this point this is Pete hagseth
making fun of the New York Times for not
covering the story this is on Friday
okay yes well thank you how did you find
any three headlines I looked for the
five Isis leaders captured in the
failing New York Times yes Stella and in
the print edition today I have not seen
it yet but we don't need that because
we've got Steve Doocy notably nonplussed
by had the reference to the failing New
York Times look at that terrible fake
news anti-trump bias Trump tweeted about
it Thursday and Fox and Friends covered
it on Friday and the New York Times just
ignored it except that the New York
Times actually reported on at first on
Wednesday night on their website and
then Thursday morning in their print
edition we actually have a screenshot
from Wednesday evening in the New York
Times five top Isis officials captured
in u.s. Iraqi sting turns out Fox and
Friends had the wrong newspaper shocker
right these people dictate policy okay
Trump watches Fox and Friends
this is state-run media or media run
State or state and media basically being
the same thing call it whatever you want
governance by idiocy is a better phrase
for it I think and someone pointed out
to me David listen Fox News knew they
were lying because Peter Hedgepeth or
whatever the guys name is said I don't
see it in the print edition meaning he
knew and they all knew that it was
online and probably they knew that it
was in a print edition for the previous
day also and we see this and we think
how dumb how silly who could be
influenced by this degree of
incompetence on Fox and Friends but
people eat this right up and you will
meet people who might not even know that
this talking point the New York Times
didn't cover the ISIS capture they might
not even know it came from Fox News or
Fox & Friends
but they'll say when you talk to them
Trump is winning he got Isis leaders
nobody talks about it the New York Times
doesn't talk about it and they obviously
wouldn't know because they certainly
don't read the New York Times so they
just listen to Pete hedge pats or
whatever this guy's name is I don't know
why I can't remember his name claim
about it is true and now I have the
correction for you right I'm gonna play
for you the video of Fox and Friends
issuing a correction about their claim
oh that's right the video doesn't exist
because they never issued such a
correction this is dangerous stuff Pat
people are falling for this stuff and
this is how these ideas get started it's
not a big deal right oh the New York
Times didn't talk about this thing well
they did but then it becomes part of the
narrative as to why the New York Times
can't be trusted and Fox and Friends
Kent yeah and you could tell that the
host was trying to play this off as an
off-the-cuff idea like right just
spontaneously came up with it yeah that
wordsmith thing I think is very telling
got it to moat this guy get Brian
Kilmeade back on the show he'll do us
justice yeah and maybe this was III
seriously have no idea what's going on
over on that program at this point
whether it's that that I know that they
have different weekends yeah but this
was Friday morning and Steve Doocy is
there and then also this other woman who
looks sort of familiar to me I don't
know what's going on with that program
but what's clear is Trump loves it and
this is it's shockingly one of the most
powerful programs in corporate media at
the
time because of the extent to which the
president is watching this show on a
regular basis from the White House let's
take a break coming up next a former
Scientologists Laurie Hudson is back on
the program she had one of our top
scientology interviews we've ever done
several years ago a lot of crazy stuff
is going on with Laurie she's gonna join
me next we've talked about the Trump
presidency as the sword of Fox News
presidency Trump watches Fox News in the
morning Fox and Friends his first tweets
of the day are often based on what was
covered on Fox and Friends that morning
we also know that Trump shares an
advisor with Sean Hannity in attorney
Michael Cohen whether or not Cohen was
ever officially representing Sean
Hannity in a legal capacity we don't
really know but we know that Cohen and
Hannity are in touch and that Hannity
has obtained advice from Cohen so a lot
of connections between Trump and Fox
News and there's now a new report from
New York magazine which points out that
on many nights of the week Trump and
Hannity are having oddly enough bed time
phone calls Trump is effectively being
put to bed by Fox News propagandist Sean
Hannity and Hannity is reportedly on a
list of cleared friends and family at
the White House switchboard he gets
right through to Donald Trump when he
calls and Trump's routine is
increasingly becoming clear on a day to
day basis in the morning Trump will
watch Fox News and tweet on the basis of
what it is he sees on TV he watches Fox
& Friends in the evenings he talks to
Sean Hannity and I was thinking as I
read this very interesting article in
New York magazine
could the contrast be starter to
President Obama who would read as much
as possible he would read fiction and
nonfiction on his own and he would read
just copious political documents in the
mornings and throughout the day and that
there could be no more antithetical
behavior to that of Barack Obama when it
comes to reading than what we're seeing
from Trump and what New York magazine
also points out is that the morning Fox
and Friends routine is not just Trump's
doing clearly Trump likes watching Fox
and Friends but apparently when Sean
Spicer and Reince Priebus were still
press secretary and chief of staff
respectively they noticed that when
Trump would get up and watch Morning Joe
for example
or other channels those had some less
than glowing reports about Trump and
Trump would get so agitated that it
would throw off his entire day so what
Priebus and Spicer decided in a sense
it's brilliant
was get Trump to watch Fox and Friends
in the morning because it keeps him more
calm and stable because they mostly just
talk about how great Trump is this is
like managing a little kid right it's
like he's got the two of the two times a
day propaganda file to placate him he's
deliberately been transitioned by staff
off of morning xuxa morning Joe over to
Fox & Friends it's like dealing with
either a kid or a developmentally
delayed adult yeah at the beginning of
his presidency it wasn't great that he
was only watching cable news right
wasn't really reading articles or
getting those presidential daily
briefings sure but at least he was
getting somewhat of a diversity of
opinions like you had people in the
center you had people on the Left who
criticized them and then you had Fox
News sure now it's just Fox News it's
exclusive and the Fox News diet
obviously has its own problems and
current officials are admitting like
here's the problem Fox News sometimes
exaggerates shocking and they also leave
out major stories if it's a story that
at its base isn't a good story for Trump
to be for the trumpets Fox News will
often just not cover it so Trump becomes
fixated because of his Fox News diet on
small insignificant stories that Fox
News focuses on and is completely in the
dark about actual major stories that are
relevant in the grand scheme of things
so it's very very disturbing what's
going on with Crump's media diet but to
get back to the Hannity phone calls for
a second Hannity's role is a little
different than Fox and Friends Hannity's
calls with Trump often leave Trump
feeling like he's just making the right
decision about everything right he's
Hannity pumps him up to think he's
accomplished amazing things Trump will
come away from these phone calls with
Hannity with new ideas for executive
orders he wants to put through and a
former White House official calls the
Hannity phone calls an effed up feedback
loop that really messes with Trump's
head so the big picture is Hannity and
Fox and friends are running our country
Fox News Corporation President Rupert
Murdoch reportedly also on that list of
people who can get right through at the
White House switchboard to Donald Trump
and there's really just no comparison to
what's happening at the White House and
I was just thinking it you know George W
Bush is really benefiting from Donald
Trump being president and the Washington
Post put out an article to that extent
and it is stunning I mean George W Bush
was a terrible president right he made
some of the worst political decisions in
a long time disastrous economy went to
war under false pretenses led to
thousands tens of thousands of civilian
and military deaths and the approval
rating retrospectively for george w bush
is way up because the contrast to donald
trump makes people say hey you know Bush
Bush wasn't really that bad and that's
dangerous number one because I've talked
before about the last thing we want to
do is get fooled into seeing the
disastrous neocon Bush doctrine of the
project for a new American Century as
anything short of horrifying but it's
true that compared to what were say I
mean but Bush at least read books right
it they weren't the books I might have
chosen necessarily but the guy was at
least reading so this is really really
scary stuff and by the way yet another
link between the Trump administration
and Julian Assange remember that Julian
Assange was in touch with Donald Trump
jr. during the campaign who of course is
directly linked to Donald Trump Julian
Assange was also in touch with Sean
Hannity during the campaign which is yet
another way in which it's completely
plausible that the Trump administration
was in touch with Assange it's another
mutual point of contact for them just
like Michael Cohen is yeah and one more
thing on Hannity I mean when Hannah he's
done when his show's over at 10 o'clock
p.m. yep do you really want to watch
Laura Ingraham or do you want to get the
bonus Hannity and I think that's what
Trump is opting to do yeah where do we
know what Trump thinks about Laura
Ingraham I don't know is that something
I think yeah he hasn't taken a position
yeah that show is unwatchable by the way
and hopefully it'll be off the air soon